[Music]
hi I'm Linda and I'm from Southie
Seattle and today we're going to make
some crazy colored pasta creations
two-tone bowtie pasta a few years ago my
adorable little son Bentley danger
developed a dislike for vegetables I
thought of all sorts of things I could
do to try to sneak vegetables into my
naughty little child finally I've
decided you know I make pasta all the
time anyway why don't I just puree the
vegetable ingredient and he'll never
know he loved eating it and he also
loved playing with it and so it was kind
of like a really cool double bonus
because it also gave us an activity to
do together that we both enjoyed we
started eating a real eight nutritious
sort of rainbow of color pasta pasta
dough should be forgiving and fun and
you should never feel like you ruined
something just because you maybe got a
ratio a little bit off
if you accidentally did add too much
flour to something the offshoot of that
is to either add a little tiny bit more
egg into it or even just a teaspoon of
water the first time I made pasta I was
probably three or four years old and it
was with my grandparents my grandparents
maybe tasked me with the more
labor-intensive things they would crack
the eggs because that took actual
technical skill then they would have me
do the kneading and the rolling out with
the rolling pin which took forever and
the funny thing is now I realize those
are the tasks that I actually assign my
son
Bentley makes pasta with me all the time
his favorite color though is red and so
I feel like he will overlook the fact
that there are beets in it even though
he knows there are beets in it because
of the fact that his actual favorite
color is red we've transcended the
vegetable in the pasta and he really
does think about it based on what he
likes color wise which i think is where
you want to be with this stuff you're
drawn to color great like all these
colors are made from fantastic things
that are good for you if you have a
pasta machine fantastic use it if you
don't have a pasta machine don't let
that intimidate you you can absolutely
just use a rolling pin and roll it out
by hand and make it a fun day among
friends or family now we're going to cut
our pasta into the final shape which
will be bow ties or farfalle in Italian
and farfalle just means butterfly kids
love to try to master the pinch kids
have tiny fingers so they do have a
little bit of an advantage on us getting
to cook together I think is just such a
great important life skill that will
help my family you know my son later on
in life but also for now it's an awesome
family activity that we can do together
I lived in Italy for a while and one of
the first multiple colored pastas I ever
saw was green and yellow backed together
I always thought that that looked so
brilliant seeing those two colors kind
of side to side
whenever possible I like to start with
fresh vegetable ingredients just because
the nutrients are more packed into those
fresh ingredients
the longer you boil the pasta the more
you're actually going to boil out the
nutrients in the pasta and so that's why
I like to roll it on the relatively thin
side and I try to keep my boils under
two minutes when I was able to get my
son involved it was just brought such a
joy to me and the fact that we were able
to do it together but I think for him
it's a confidence builder and it's
something that later in life he's always
going to cherish and always going to
appreciate I love nothing more than when
he brings a group of his nine year old
boy friends over and they all want to
jump in the kitchen and cook together
[Music]
tasty oh yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]